[Music]
the kidnapper said he would call with
drop instructions at 8am it is now
801. cheddar's dead cheddar is not dead
it's just one minute perhaps the
kidnapper's watch is slow oh dear god if
this watch is slow there's no telling
what else this psychopath is capable of
raymond cheddar is fine he's coming back
to us and that is why i bought a new gps
tag to put on his collar thank you
kevin at least some of us are thinking
clearly yes crystal clear in fact i
bought five gps tags one for his collar
and one for each arm and leg i'm going
to make bracelets to put them on
and i'll never lose my cheddar again
okay a little unsettling but i like your
positivity
three minutes after eight this man is
unhinged you said you'd call it eight my
watch is slow
put the files on a flash drive and have
your husband bring it to the ninth
street entrance of prospect park at noon
my husband no i'm not involving him in
this i'll bring them myself
i don't trust you i told you not to look
for me but you did send your husband or
the deal is off
clearly we're not doing this no it's
fine we can just alter the files and
give him fakes he'll never know it's not
that it's that i refuse to put kevin in
harm's way
understood but i think maybe i have a
way to put kevin in danger without
putting kevin in danger
well hello there raymond teach me kevin
and i am detective jacob peralta you
didn't have anything else to wear so he
just switched
he understands
[Music]
okay if we're gonna pull this off we
need to teach you how to move
talk and act exactly like kevin in other
words we have ourselves a pygmalion
situation exactly a pig
mailman situation right it'll be okay
well it'll be okay let's get started yes
let's get started it's getting worse
spot on kevin
look raymond a yellow crusted warbler
look raymond
a yellow crested warbler no you're too
excited the warbler's a common bird
and then i said which metamorphosis
kafka or ovid
i loved it he loves it oh so that's the
joke
no you tell it oh okay so a professor
walks into a rare books collection
no you've ruined it now it's not funny
look remind
a yellow-crested warbler look raymond a
yellow-crusted word
ugh not excited enough they may be
common but they're still
birds the 92nd street y had a wonderful
symposium on just that topic
that's it you're getting it ah
don't say cool instead say indeed no
indeed indeed indeed indeed indeed
that's weird look raymond a yellow
crusted warbler yes
that's the right level of excitement for
such a bird you've captured the essence
of kevin
you've done it correction i've
accomplished it
indeed indeed indeed indeed indeed
it's growing on me
you